GUILLERMO RAUCH:
Thank you so much.
My name is Guillermo Rauch, as
I was introduced earlier today,
the creator of
Socket.IO I was involved
very early on with the
Node.js community working
on everything from trying
bring in the core APIs
to a point where they
were useful to us
at our first startup all the
way to creating new frameworks
and supporting
existing frameworks.
We worked with some of the
greatest Node.js people,
like TJ Holowaychuk and
Nate Rajlich, Marco Aurelio.
And today I'm going to
talk about something
more encompassing and
something more generic
then just Node.js, Specifically
about real time web
applications and how I look
at real time web applications.
When I was just thinking
about the title of my talk
earlier today, I
started thinking
about how we don't have
a definition for it
or how when we say
real time, we'll
think maybe about
different things.
And some of you might
think about websockets.
Some of you might think
about, for example,
data that refreshes over
time, maybe regardless of how
we convey or move that
data from different points.
I'll start by talking
about a definition
that I've come to after working
with lots of different web
applications.
All the way before
Node.js existed
through Comet and all
the things that we
want to do with
those technologies.
The first conclusion
that have come to
is that when people
think about real time
and they think about actually
just moving data really fast.
They think about refreshing
data with minimal latency.
So it's all about the user
thinking that the data's not
stale, that what they're
looking at on the screen
is a representation of the
latest and greatest that's
available on the
server, and that that's
coming with minimal latency.
It's coming really fast
after it gets to the server.
So if you're chatting,
someone sends a message,
you want to get that
message to someone
else as fast as possible.
And the other really
important aspect
is that that data to the
user has update automatically
and uniformly.
So automatically
means that they're not
pressing the Refresh
button, for example,
or they're not keeping
track themselves
of updating that data.
And the other aspect of it is
that if a portion of the screen
that's representing
some data on the server
updates, and there's
another reference
to that data within
the same application,
both are synchronized.
So the data updates everywhere.
And that all comes down to you
write a web application that
does never require that the
user presses F5, for example.
And what I like
about this definition
is that it's
actually pretty easy
to summarize it in two
things, despite all
those long explanations.
So your time application
needs to be fast,
and it needs to
be self-updating.
So I'll go with this definition
for the rest of this talk.
And just to put it in context
of an example of an application
that you might write, I thought
about a traditional real time
application, which is
a stock ticker showing
the value of a
stock in real time.
And I'll start with
some simple HTML, which
has summary presentation
on the user's screen.
And then we add some
naive JavaScript
to make sure that's up to date.
Usually when we approach
a problem like this,
it's hard to decide
on what timer we're
going to set on the front end.
This has been a long
subject of debate.
For example, when you
implement long polling,
is how long does the
polling duration need to be,
or how fast do we need to try to
get more data from the server?
So we'll just go with
15 seconds right now.
And then we assume
that the server
at the start of this timeline
thinks that the price is 500.
And disclaimer, I don't
know what the price is.
I just came up with this.
So the user goes to the page.
And then of course, we're
going to request some JSON API.
We're going to get
that the price is 500.
And then we wait
15 seconds, which
of course is
completely arbitrary.
At this point, it's where this
application sort of breaks
down and stops being
as fast as it could
be because the price
might have changed,
but your front end
will keep waiting.
And see, it's Friday night,
and it's really slow.
No one likes it.
I don't like it.
But we have to wait.
Yeah.
And then the front end
decides to get it again,
and then, boom,
it updates to 505.
The user at this point has
no idea what the server knew.
And they didn't know that
it could have gotten faster,
it's just your application
just became slow.
So in this case, the front
end is self-updating.
So I think this is
where a lot of people
might be confused with, is my
application real time or not.
Because if it's self-updating,
you might think it's real time.
But in this case, it doesn't
satisfy the other condition
that we set.
It's fast and it's sad,
and it makes me cry.
The next thing you might
think is an optimization.
You might think, oh Guillermo,
you said 15 seconds.
It could have been
just immediate.
So now boom, it's fast
and self-updating.
So even though it's fast,
or it might be fast,
as I'll show next, in fact just
because you're requesting data
from a client to
the server, it's
not as fast as it could be.
Because the server is really the
source of truth of this data.
So the server is the
one that first finds out
about the latest price,
and technically is
the one that should
let the client know.
The client doesn't need to ask.
But by performing this
loop of get request,
we also have a side effect.
That is, we increase
latency by having
to ask all the time, and then
of course server resources.
And the natural conclusion
was that it's much better
to have the server push data
to us with, boom, Socket.IO.
Let's see that again.
Boom.
Beautiful, right?
You're like this at this point.
Yeah, I actually have
come to the conclusion
that push is also
not necessarily
part of the definition of
a real time application.
And I'd like to explain with
an analogy, which is you go,
and this is you.
This [INAUDIBLE] has a body.
And you think you're hungry.
And boom, idea.
Let's go to $7 Coffee
Cafe in Mission Dolores.
So the analogy goes like this.
You go and request the
menu from the server.
So this is the
traditional-- this the way
that I usually explain the
traditional request response
model.
You just sit there.
You get something.
You get some
response right away.
So this waiter's kind of weird,
and he goes, 200 OK menu.
And then he goes back to
whatever he was doing.
He idles.
And this is what
Node.js is good at.
It's good at idling
and handling all
this request-response cycles.
And you're like, I know
what I'm going to get.
It's a bagel.
And in this case,
there's no response.
HTTP is a great [INAUDIBLE]
for modeling this.
It's just OK, I'll
let someone know.
The metaphor is really good.
They find out that the kitchen
is actually a web service.
So the guy goes, and
he goes, bagel, OK.
And then idles again.
So this is where I think
the web disappointed us,
in which if we were expecting
some update from someone else,
it was usually
really hard to do.
And what we've been
doing up until this point
is always asking.
So you become really upset, and
you're like, what's the status?
And then you're incurring
more load to the server
because you need to check again.
The kitchen gets really upset
because they're like, dude,
we're still working on it.
And the guy is still pretty
chill with his glasses
and his OK.
And one second later, boom.
Here's you again asking again.
This is kind of like our
stock ticker example.
You're like, yeah,
I'll just ask again.
There's no problem.
But then what happens,
there's other people
that are interested in
consuming this service.
They all look like you, too.
And the result is
server congestion.
This is a single
thread of JVM, and it's
really bad at
handling many things.
So what's the
solution of course is
that we push all
this to the client
without the client
requesting him.
In this case, it
models back to someone
announcing something and
delivering to the clients,
which we call events.
And this is how we think
about it in Socket.IO.
But I'd like to make the
distinction that it's
technically still
not required that you
do push to satisfy the two
conditions that we set.
So one of the ways that
people have circumvented this,
if you reduce proximity from
the client to the server,
so you minimize the
latency, in this case
by having the waiter
right next to the guy,
then you may think that your
application's real time just
because the latency of
the request response cycle
is so low that to the
end user, it's real time.
And the other thing that you
have to do to make this work
is you have to increase
server capacity.
So it would be equivalent to
having tons of capacity just
because you're expecting
so much more load.
So if you do these
two things, you
do effectively have a
real time application.
And then now that
example that I set up
would actually work really well.
So what I want to
point to with this
is that real time is more
about the user experience.
It's not so much about
what stack you decide on
or what transfer's you're using.
There's two
implications that I've
thought of that come with
setting up an application that
is both fast and self-updating.
So as far as making
your application fast,
the speed at which you basically
make the data transfer work
is going to determine how
real time your application is.
And I've come to understand
that real time is
more of a gradient, rather
than a binary classification.
And an example that I
remember from many years
ago when I was just getting
started with Socket.IO
was Google Docs.
There was a little startup
here in San Francisco
called EtherPad that defined
themselves as really real time.
So this was their way of saying
that, even though there were
real time systems
available like Google Docs,
they were sort of pointing
to them standing alone
in that regard.
And also they were
pointing to how
Google was taking an arbitrary
length of time, as opposed
to being as immediately
as it could be.
So this kind of points to
that first naive example
that we're doing.
And they give a
great example of how
most of the communication
that we do in real life
doesn't really have this
sort of arbitrary latency.
So at the time, I
think Google satisfied
the self-updating thing, but it
wasn't as fast as it could be.
So someone came up with a
little start-up in this case
and made something
better, got acquired.
Boom, now they're in
some beach in Hawaii.
No, they're probably
just working here.
They're maybe here.
Friday night, thinking
about real time.
One of the things
they did was they
switched from an algorithm
of how they conversed changes
in the text.
And I'm not sure
about this one, but I
think they were just polling
and implementing long polling.
So they focused on making
the user experience better.
And the other implication that
comes with these two conditions
for real time applications
is that if you're
going to make your
application self-updating,
it can't just be self-updating
while the network is working
perfectly, or during the
beginning of the session.
And you have to make
it work all along.
And right connection's one of
the things that you have to do.
So you're setting up
an expectation, which
is for the user, the
data is always up to date
and coming in.
And they're not going to be
used to thinking that they
need to press the
refresh button.
So one of the consequences
is that you have to make sure
that the user knows that if
there's a network problem,
or if they're disconnected,
that you're trying to reconnect.
And of course, most of
the real time applications
that you use today, like Google
Chat or Facebook Messenger,
do a good job of doing this.
But another thing that is
really important to consider
is what I call state
reconciliation,
or we could call it
resynchronization.
And a test that I run most
applications is-- especially
the ones that are
self-updating--
is what happens if I'm
looking at something that's
updating in real time,
I close my laptop lid,
and I come back to
it a week later?
I just open it, and what
happens to that session?
And it turns out
that the front end
needs to keep a few things
in mind that maybe we're
not used to thinking about.
One of them is that the
session could have expired.
So the application
doesn't know how
to rerender itself in a
logged out state, for example,
dynamically.
User login changed.
So there's a chance that
maybe from another tab,
or you validated this
session remotely.
So you actually have
to reping the screen
with a completely
different user.
Or more concerningly, you might
have been offline for so long
that the delta is really big.
And in many cases, it's not
even worth showing entirely.
So there's a lot of systems that
make your application satisfy
the condition of being
self-updating by ensuring
that they synchronize
every change that happens
over time to any data
the user's looking at.
But then they're going to
hit a problem when you're
offline for a very long
time because of two reasons.
One is you might overwhelm
the user with data.
But even if the
user can handle it,
it may not even be relevant.
So if you're offline looking at
a Twitter stream or a Facebook
stream for a very
long period of time,
by the time a week
has passed, it
doesn't even make sense to
get the entire [INAUDIBLE].
You might just want
to get the tail,
and also handle it
appropriately on the front end.
The conclusion is
also that you have
to be careful with the
signing in around an event
log of sorts, where if
the user's subscribing
to some data, your
front end assumes
that every subsequent
change with that fault
is going to be retrieved.
And finally, I'd like to
mention an important caveat that
comes with basically designing
this type of application.
Or I should say, at this
time it's sort of a risk
that a lot of us run into.
I think in the effort to making
our web applications feel
alive and self-updating, because
it's so rewarding to the user
and sometimes so rewarding
to the developer,
we've forgotten that we're
actually maybe making it
fast during the
lifetime of the session,
but in the beginning when we're
loading our web application,
it's actually
really, really slow.
So a term that I
object to as of today,
because it dawned on me
today that single page app
is a really bad name
for what we want to do.
Because in some
cases, it implies
that we're giving
up server rendering.
There's only one page, which
means your server handles
every URL the same
way, which is not good,
and we're going to see why.
In most cases, this type of
application incurs in too many
hops in the network to give
the user data he wants.
And in many cases, they
also give up the information
that they have of the URL.
If the user comes to
you with a certain URL,
you already can prepare
the data that he wants to.
You don't have to download a
huge single page application
script, then evaluate
it, then get the data.
And I think this happens
a lot because there's
a lot of progress being made
in the frameworks that we use.
So React.js, Socket.IO,
all these frameworks
are really exciting.
But we're forgetting
about basically
how that first request works.
So a useful reminder
is that we're all
operating under the assumption
that TCP is how we establish
that first connection
to the server,
and that's how we get the data.
Google is working on making
improvements to TCP end
cobbling it in such a
way that it works better
for SPDY connections.
But for the moment, we have TCP
as a foundation of everything
we do in real time
web obligations.
The data is sent in segments
over a sliding window that
acts as a congestion
control mechanism.
And we have to keep
in mind that data
is sent to the user
in a growing way.
So initially, it just is only
able to send four segments.
I like always
stealing this slide
from Paul Irish that points
to how much data the client
is able to absorb over time
for every TCP connection.
And then he has really
interesting numbers
for the equivalent
in 3G connections.
And it kind of shows-- it kind
of puts it into perspective
how bad it is to make the user
load all these huge single page
applications.
The conclusion is that
the first 14 kilobytes
are the most important to make
the application feel really
fast in that initial load time.
So my conclusion is that
the most optimal real time
application will have
to necessarily render
data on the server, or at the
very least render a placeholder
of where you're going
to fill in the data.
So part of it or
completely, you have
to render data on the server,
and it's not a choice.
So I think when I
was asked to talk
about the future of
real time applications,
I think most of the
future will have
to do with investment in making
this faster because we've
made the lifetime of
the application fast.
Like once everything
is loaded, everything
is super fast and self-updating.
But that initial connection
is actually pretty slow.
It's very important that the
client side then takes over,
once that initial
server render happens.
Because if our goal is to
minimize latency and make
the application really
fast, JavaScript
is uniquely positioned to
do that because we can even
mask the actual network
latency by using JavaScript
in the client to make the front
end behave optimistically.
And an example that
I always mention
is, you write a
chat application,
and it doesn't matter
how optimized it is.
It doesn't matter that you use
the transport with the lowest
amount of framing,
like WebSocket.
At the end of the
day, most applications
will actually insert
or repane the screen
once you hold down
your Enter key.
Because that's the
best user experience.
They're not just
waiting for the network.
So basically we do need this
basically initial really fast
server load in many cases
with server rendering data,
and then we have to have
the client take over.
Because otherwise,
we're giving up
on these really amazing
optimizations and opportunities
to mask latency.
So even if the
network is terrible,
client side JavaScript
will always make it better.
So the consequence that
I was mentioning earlier,
or the implication that we
have to be really mindful
of reconciliation
and reconnection
is even more
important in this case
because you have to think
of the server rendering
some data as basically
a connection that
disconnects immediately.
Then the data gets
transferred to the client.
Then the JavaScript
loads or whatever,
and the connection
gets started up again.
And then at that
point, there's a chance
that from the moment that
the server rendered the page,
data could have changed.
That's why you have
to always think
of these self-updating
applications
through the lens of the
worst case scenario, which
is there's a lot
of disconnections
and reconnections.
And to make this
seamless, and I think
this is sort of the
conclusion, is the ability
to share code is going
to be uniquely important.
So the future is what it's
always been about, I think,
which is make your app
deliver data faster.
And I think writing JavaScript
on the server with Node.js
is going to be really
helpful for that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]